[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants avec ninon
mais ils ont rasé
bonjour bonjour niveau alors qu'est ce
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui cette leçon
pour débutants donc aujourd'hui on
parlait d' importante ouverture avait
bien débuté la partie bien développer
les pièces comme il faut là où il faut
et cette importance et après où on voir
exemple si on me fait signe pas ainsi
qu'est ce qui peut arriver
ce qui peut se passer qu'est ce qui se
passait alors attention donc en général
on dit pour les ouvertures qu'il faut
contrôler le centre
oui sortir les pièces rock et oui pour
sécuriser leurs war sécuriser le roi et
enfin avant d'engager deux des
manoeuvres plus importante oui donc à
venir
je suis sûr vous avez déjà remarqué
presse que les parties d'échecs commence
par quatre t4 parce que ce sont les
pions centro et donc on essaye d'obtenir
tout de suite le centre est pourquoi on
fait ainsi si on sort trop et les pièces
imaginées qu'il ya un but bien que vous
ont juste à fait je sais pas
on introduit les pièces trop tombe dans
le centre tout simplement l'adversaire
les attaquer et on sera obligé de
reculer après d'ailleurs dans cette
partie de d'exemplaires on va voir ça
par exemple si les noirs on ne contrôle
pas bien le centre au revoir jusqu'à où
peut aller les pieds de l'adversaire
dans le centre alors on va voir s'il ya
juste donc à retenir d'un goût développé
ça y est d'abord pousser les pions un
petit pot pour ouvrir pour les
diagonales pour les fous après sortir
les cavaliers à savoir pour les
cavaliers les meilleurs cas c'est
considérer sur f3 et c3 je sais pas bien
sourit on peut vous montrer
il travaille énormément ne va pas se
rater trois haut à 3 mai sur i see where
vers le centre donc le centre je vous
rappelle donc c'est voilà ces deux cases
sont naturels en général pour les
cavaliers
oui juste dernières rencontres
conseillers on veut dire très très
important évitez de jouer avec la même
pièce d'ouverture
c'est un plaisir il faut pas faire trois
ou quatre ou cinq coups avec l'un avec
la même pièce sinon vous aurez retrait
très grand retard de développement
surtout on a fait toutes les pièces juin
vous êtes vous fait jouer deux pièces
mais aussi ça le dire tous les pieds ça
veut pas dire forcément et on connait
tous rentrer en vous un peu plus tard
toutes les pièces ont dit si vous avez
sources et les cavaliers et les fous ont
eu un effet rock on peut dire le
développement les plus souvent terminé
c'est là qu'est la double pensée terme
et après plus tard des pièces alors on y
va on va regarder un petit exemple ici
de d'ouverture donc on sort un pion du
centre alors soit celui ci soit le pion
de la dame en général je veux bien sûr
si vous débutez donc il vaut mieux
il faut me suivre ces conseils là donc
les débutants en général on conseille
plutôt de jouer les pionniers roi qui
s'occupe des positions plus aéré mais
ces questions de style en général les
joueurs plus prudents préférant
peut-être joué le plan de la dame des
positions un peu plus tranquille alors
que eux quatre ou cinq les noirs
répondre par un coup symétrique au
centre entre les centres donc on sort
une pièce alors si on sort les cavaliers
sur les bonnes cases et ça empêche pas
qu il faut les sortir quand ils sont
actifs
donc en l'occurrence on joue donc
d'abord seul ce cavalier là pourquoi
parce que tout de suite
il attaque on attaque le pion central
donc si on avait joué l'autre il attaque
est rien donc il était un peu plus
passif il faut peut-être attendre avant
de sentir le deuxième cavani les noirs
répondent par un coup à la fois de
cavaliers sur une bonne case et en même
temps qui défend le pion c'est un
classique de faire les cons vraiment
très utile qui essaiera plusieurs jours
alors il yad'autres coup on pourrait
jouer le coup avions ici des six avec
michael des avantages de bloquer le fond
on pourrait envisager aussi le coup car
ici ce qui contre attaque
vérifions centrale il ya d'autres idées
on peut aussi contre attaqué avec une
tontine très bon il ya plein d'idées
mais il faut que ça soit cohérent on est
tous classés 4e place ex aequo blessé
six voix là qu'avaient laissé six
classiques alors là les blancs
continuent leur développement
logiquement fous ces quatre donc normal
mais c'est la partie ce qu'on appelle
italienne poussé quatre est tout de
suite d'ailleurs on va pouvoir au quai
voyez comme ça va vite fait les choses
dans l'ordre
oui une l'idée c'est ça pourra rockets
aussi vous voyez les bleus n'ont pas
fait tout de suite des trois pour pas
bloquer le fou et voilà si on joue les
coups des trois on aurait bloqué ce
fouet alors qu'ici il est bien placé
les noirs peuvent pas la tati facilement
il
il contrôle une belle diagonale à
retenir d'abord vous si vous avez la
possibilité
d'abord on le sait sortir le fou et
après bouger l'autre et on est comme ça
vous avez de foot et ça nous a évité un
terme aux prix hors la loi les noirs
font un coup un peu présomptueux s'ils
jouent le plus fou b4 et là on va voir
pourquoi c'est pas un super coup parce
que tu as monaco va un peu trop loin ce
alors l'intérêt l'idée dé nord s'étai se
dire que les banques peuvent pas jouer
le pion central puisque le roi sourire
en échec - d'abord un on peut faire
petit rock oui mais de on peut aussi
gagner du temps tout de suite en jouant
le coup ces trois voilà ces trois quarts
du temps sur le fou on va être obligé de
reculer ce fou et ce pion est
intéressant parce qu'il va protéger la
case centrale ligne et donc permettre
une poussée central 1 donc d'où
l'intérêt des pions sans trois
voilà et apparemment c'est qu'elle est
noire ne savait pas c'est que déjà dans
parties et allié l'idée de blanc c'est
ça à faire ces trois étaient quatre pour
obtenir le centre portant corps est ici
les notes tout simplement aider les
blancs à réaliser leur plan avait donc
là on perd du temps on est obligé de
rejouer le coup le fonds a été attaqué
par un petit rock des blancs d'abord
c'est que vous êtes toujours le roi
avant d'ouvrir avant passer à l'action à
ouvrir les diagonales les colonnes et
c'est toujours pensé d'abord m
le roi à l'abri à la pause et après
après vous commencez ouverte aux
attaques et sert à passer à l'action
alors lui noire continue en
développement avec calais six voire dix
longs tours par ok et donc c'est le bon
moment pour les pour les poules et blanc
pour lancer une opération dès 4 ans et
ayant un problème déjà tout de suite sur
le fond ces cinq alors les noirs pour il
peut si on sort le fou tout de suite on
prendrait avec les blancs ont des six si
on mettait le fou en défense ici à
lorient ça protège bien le problème
c'est que qu'est-ce que je fais moi j'ai
fait faire
bêtise nos adieux à remplacer la partie
alors si on si on joue et c'est pas
grave s'ils ont joué le fou j'ai
remplacé je crois sur le jouet le fou
ici en fait on bloquera c'est pas grave
on bloquerait le pion le pion en d6 donc
on empêcherait le fou s'est mis debout
j'ai donc assure des quatre les noirs
prennent ici en d4
les blancs reprennent ici en d4 et les
noirs maintenant sont négligés par une
de jouer la casse b6 vers le fond il on
trouve par ok on va dire l'un deux
pièces entre autres réformes oui qui ont
qui créent des menaces sur les who les
noirs et par exemple ou encore attaqué
le collège des cinq par ex donc par
exemple on peut jouer des cinq mon cas
les recettes versées encore passer ou
pas d'être c'était on peut envisager ça
y est voilà le problème par contre à
kevin cès sera au même même si on règle
et après il y avait 4 qui arrive aux
menaces des cafés philo vallier callas
pas on espère le cavalier et on aura du
mal à empêcher ou 5 aussi donc sur le
coup cavalier 7,7 on peut regarder on
peut pousser le deuxième plus haut oui
qu'est ce qui se passe et essayer
concrètement quand les noirs ont sorti
les pièces mais ça nous vraiment d'abord
laisser passer les pions et sert à ça
manquait des espaces les blancs chaque
coup la tap une pièce les noirs au lieu
de se développer offert rockstar et non
pas tant parce que chaque fois les
menaces il y avait le fou qui était
menacé deux fois kylie qui menacent
maintenant de cavaliers deuxième fois ça
fait quatre ans que les noirs font les
coudes défense et du coup entre 7 ans
l'épreuve l'on prend de plus en plus
davantage
c'est pour ça il faut pas laisser comme
ça s'écrasait sur les malades vers ça va
se faire écraser une fois que si les
noirs jouent sous cavaliers par exemple
angers 4e 4
manger car émanant d'un porte à porte on
peut jouer encore le coût 1,5 et alors
regardez là le pion débloquer donc ce
four a beaucoup de mal à sortir en plus
à des menaces de [ __ ] un cavalier
échec
oui suivi de cavale et j'ai cinq cordes
et le phocéen qui protège le cavalier
donc là vous par exemple qu'il a passés
complètement au perdant perdant l'or
parce que là imaginons donc les noirs
prennent une première fois on reprend le
câble étant prises il faut bouger le
cavalier par exemple au f5
voilà et tout de suite on peut jouer par
exemple coup comme dam des cinq ou six
qui est très fort puisque on attaque à
la fois le club pion à vii et le
quatrième pouvoir
cette possibilité oui les choses comme
ça aussi mais ce qu'on regarde et se
reprendre une telle enfoncé en cavale et
j'ai cinq échecs le fou protège de
cavale et donc la dame peut pas prendre
et sur roy par exemple pluie ici par
exemple g6pd simplement prend le kg 4
avec un roi totalement en l'air des
rockets sans protection vous voyez que
le fou s'éviter complètement enfermé
c'est pour ça c'était important qu'elle
est noire quelque part face indécise
pour ouvrir ces fous qui est resté
complètement hors de vous voilà tout ça
est lié au fait que les noirs ont joué
ce coup là ici bizarre fou b4 qui a
donné un tempo de plus oui ils sont
tombés chaque poisson sur les menace
alors il faut donc il faut pas faire ça
en fait voilà qu'on
et prendre en compte les menaces
d'adversaires et pas placer les ps
justement les pions en observant
systématiquement il faut pas quand même
de ces pièces devant devant les tueurs à
la différence aujourd'hui c'est que le
fou c4 ne peut pas être attaquée par des
pions ces sanctions qui seraient perdus
il est bien placé une bonne case il est
à la fois a bien avancé dans le camp
blanc mais pas au contact des pions
noirs donc ici ça fait 4 c'est un peu
trop présomptueux tons clairs on va voir
une partie qu'il ressemble à celle ci
beaucoup ou les noirs ont un type au
mieux jouer et ils ont plus joué coupé 4
mais fou c'est simple on va voir dans
que 4,5 dont toujours l'ouverture donc
on sort la pièce ward et on attaque le
pion central défense de la part des
noirs tous ces quatre ici c'est 5 pouces
et 5
donc wait and 1,84 et des très mauvais
donc là c'est la 7 mai normal donc on
joue ces trois maintenant mais voyez un
coup de moins quand même un énorme les
deux latéraux rien fait et noir tallinn
voilà les gars jouent d'abord cabaye m6
et le roi a pas bougé ici parce que donc
sur des 4 puis on prend des quatre
s'éprend des cannelés noah aurait pu
jouer ici le couffo b4 chèque qui
maintenant est bon parce qu'il ya plus
de pions qui peuvent venir en c3 et mais
là en fait les noirs font une autre
erreur ce qu'ils oublient soukous
d'échecs qui d'un coup important oui il
suffit de faire en comblant est ça peut
vraiment tout de suite donné une
résultat massacrant bien sûr donc ici
sauf au v6 on a le même problème
quasiment dans la partie précédente
il aurait fallu jouer le coup phobie
quatre échecs nous faut être pour faire
route au dessus d'un premier et après
roque et très vite pour éviter toutes
les toutes les menaces et apprécié de
contre-attaquer supions on se centre
mais avec un roi à l'abri c'est quand
même plus facile
means to b 6 et la d5 est ovale
cavaliers horde et au centre il ya le
travail étroit qui bien développés qui
contrôle toutes les cases du centre
si on vient à 5 il suffit de jouer le
fou en d3 et on menace à la fois de
jouer eux cinq est aussi le coupé 4 qui
attaquent le cavalier
à cinq ans tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
c'est le maire casse du coup quand les
sept que le set et là c'est étonnant
mais ça marche toujours leur chose même
saint roch saint qui ont un problème sur
cavaler g4 qui étonne beaucoup de contre
attaque on attaque ici pourquoi parce
qu'on attaque la kz2 en protégeant avec
le fou b6 e-menaces fourchette après on
menace une fourchette sur la dame et la
tour on pourrait rockets donc oui oui
c'est un si vous voulez oui mais dans
ces cas les noirs au scirocco et même si
les bleus n'ont aucun avantage
apparemment les plans ils sont entrés
pratiquement tout de suite les temps
fort c'est ici donc c'est mieux
donc ils jouent les blancs jouent le
coup des six est encore plus fort juste
une chose à retenir aussi aux échecs
c'est pas juste le matériel qui compte
il faut surtout ce qui compte c'est
l'initiative des pièces activités
activités de pis c'est ça à regarder
premièrement quand vous regardez une
position et après qui plus de pièces est
celle là si on regarde on voit tout de
suite que les noirs sont très
bizarrement bloqué avec le foot c'est
vite tout ça se joue sur trois a fait
regarder le problème de sous c'est le
cavalier sur cette question ne soit donc
a encore attaqué c'est encore à temps
perdu ou s'il part lourds ou est
toujours dans le centre est sont
vraiment mal et le dans ce type de
position même s'il peut faire fourchette
à howard donc on attaque d'âmes et où
c'est pas un problème peuvent facilement
ses cris fier quelques pièces voilà est
tout de suite passé à l'offensive voilà
on doit on va voir par exemple ici dame
b3 en fait simplement en fait on ne peut
pas reprendre le câble évidemment donc
fallait sortir la dame et l'idée c'est
qu'on laisse à vassy des noirs prennent
pas la tour on pourra jouer tour eiffel
d'ailleurs on peut voir dans la marianne
savary attachant par exemple qu'elle les
prend
la casa chiens ont fait [ __ ] en effet
cet échec et après roy fuite forcée un
bris le simple coût fou j'ai cinq noms
et en prévoit effet de forcer pardon ou
g5 et on peut pas empêcher avec les
noirs s mais si on prend une première
fois suffira de reprendre avec les pions
on peut pas empêcher fou prend où nous
pillons pas encore plus fort ou peut
comprendre on faisait pareil qui gagnent
la dame en fait voilà parce que ça fera
un échec avec fort on ne peut pas
empêcher la dame ne peut pas sortir et
vous voyez le comme des coulées qui
m'appartient voilà c'est terminé on peut
pas bouger donc en fait ça perd tout de
suite voyez vous la voyez comme ça va
vite donc c'est très agressive ou voyez
une chose aussi à savoir si vous avez
avantage développement à l'ouverture il
faut essayer de renforcer la position
parce que si vous jouez trop lentement
cet avantage va disparaître parce que
c'est un avantage
éphémère c'est pas forcément durable oui
il suffit que vous vouez très lentement
nous contentant du fait que vous avez
avantage de développement mais dans ces
cas l'adversaire ou s'il va ressortir
ses pièces il va égaliser la position
par exemple donc si vous avez un
avantage qu'il faudra agresser
l'adversaire c'est comme ça que vous
pouvez profiter des avantages si vous
faites rien ça va disparaître
ça va disparaître simplement parce
qu'elle lui aussi va sortir des pièces
donc arrête retenir ça passait à
l'action tout de suite et mettre un
maximum de pression soit sur le roi
donc si si les noirs ici fonfon petit
rock et camp sans doute le moins le
moins graves
on peut on peut encore sur le poteau et
fun nord qui doit pas être mauvais moi
même j'ai cinq accords très fort aux
fous j'ai scène on l'est on laisse la
tour puisque toute façon s'ils ne
reprenne la course par hamon prend ici
avec les pions et on ferme on reprendra
la tour derrière la tour et fuite avec
l'ambition davantage puisqu'on aura
gagné une pièce aux usa on aura gagné
une pièce de plus puisque on uk on aura
gagné la tour et le et le cavalier noir
voilà donc on voit très vite que le
développement prime et le contrôle du
centre donc s'annoncer des exemples très
généraux si vous voulez plus
d'information sur la partie italienne ce
qui est pas le but de l'émission mais
plus d'informations il ya une leçon
spécifique diagonale tv leçons alors
c'est pas pour les débutants c'est pour
les joueurs plus confirmés
mais si on voit le concept d'ouverture
générale qui est de dire bombay il faut
développer rapidement les pièces et des
pions et éviter de perdre du temps comme
ici qu'on a vu essayer d'éviter que
l'adversaire prennent le centre avec ses
pions tant qu c'est une avenue que les
noirs où ils ont perdu de temps avec les
cavaliers finalement les cavaliers il on
n'a pas arrêté de voyager sur
l'échiquier moyenne et c'est pour ça ils
ont pris c'est très tard de
développement la foule vite et de se
faire harceler les pièces
donc merci niveau pour cette leçon
spéciale donc concept très généraux sur
les ouvertures
après plus de détection ouverture obama
étudie en particulier mais c'est des
concepts qui sont applicables et même
pour les plus grands un joueur du monde
et vous pouvez retrouver même pour les
débutants les cours sur vienne intérêts
sur les ouvertures qu'on va faire
bientôt la situation arthur tout à fait
on peut profiter voir ses cours voilà
merci de nous avoir suivis pour cette
émission puis je vous dis à bientôt sur
la lointaine merci nino
[Musique]